from California now a red hot issue went
to a whole new level this afternoon the
administration is suing that state over
its refusal to cooperate with federal
law over illegal immigration and it's
getting nasty in the Golden State
correspondent Clara Cowan has that story
tonight in Sacramento how dare you
needlessly endanger the lives of our law
enforcement officers to promote a
radical open borders agenda attorney
general jeff sessions threw down the
gauntlet in California
blasting state politicians for their
sanctuary policies and accusing them of
deliberately obstructing federal
immigration law by protecting illegal
immigrants California absolutely appears
to me is using every power it has powers
it doesn't have to frustrate federal law
enforcement president trump showed his
support while speaking to the Latino
coalition earlier today and it's
destroying people's lives so many and
we're going to stop it the Justice
Department is specifically targeting
three California state laws enacted
within the past year one prohibits law
enforcement from asking people about
their immigration status and from
participating in federal enforcement
raids another gives state officials
power over DHS detention facilities and
the third offers protection against
workplace raids this lawsuit marks an
escalation in the ongoing feud between
the Trump administration and immigration
advocates hundreds of whom showed up to
protest chanting shut it down and
blocking the street around the hotel
where sessions delivered his remarks
California's Democratic governor and
attorney general angrily condemned the
DOJ lawsuit as a political stunt
contending their state's sanctuary
policies are on solid legal ground this
is completely unprecedented for the
chief law enforcement of the United
States to come out here and engage in a
political stunt
make wild accusations many of which are
based on outright lies the lawsuit
challenges some of our state laws which
are again fully constitutional in an
exclusive interview with Fox News's
Shannon breeze
sessions vowed to keep fighting somebody
needs to stand up and say no you've gone
too far you cannot do this this is not
reasonable it's radical really and the
Justice Department is reportedly now
looking at other states that have
sanctuary policies they could face legal
action next meantime here in California
both sides are gearing up for a long
legal fight no matter what the district
judge decides the loser will appeal and
this case will likely end up before the
US Supreme Court
Lori Callan thank you in Sacramento